Nickelodeon's Doug is still a major source
of nostalgia for early millennials who grew
up in the splat-TV era. The diary-style cartoon
series centered on the life of a boy in small-town
Bluffington as he grappled with the typical
issues of youth — from navigating an unrequited
infatuation to concealing a superhero alter
ego. Doug Funnie's life was both relatable
and charming to watch. But what you may not
know about the series is how it became so
beloved in the first place — and how it
hit a few major speed bumps along the way.
Here's a look back at some things you might
not know about Doug.
The life of Brian
It’s hard to imagine Doug as being about
anyone except, well, Doug -- but creator Jim
Jinkins originally had another name in mind.
In 2012, Jinkins told Splitsider that since
the character was supposed to have a very
"any guy" look, he wanted to name him something
completely blasé. Jinkins explained,
"At the beginning, I was calling him 'Brian.'
It was sort of just a generic name. [...] I
thought that 'Doug' had that feeling and that
sound about it. It was a conscious choice
because I wanted him to be this very neutral,
middle-of-the-road guy."
Doug's middle name, Yancey, also had some
significance for Jinkins, as it was shared
by own his grandfather. Doug's embarrassment
ov er it stemmed from a very real place, as
he had a childhood friend who also hated his
own name growing up, much to Jinkins' amusement.
“Hello there, Yancey!”
“My name’s Doug."
Ad man
Jinkins' Doug doodles originally existed as
a sort of "alter ego" for the artist, who
said he desperately needed an outlet from
the real world, where problems are a lot more
complicated than they are for the residents
of his pseudo-utopia Bluffington. Jinkins
once explained of the character's origin,
"I like to doodle, [and] Doug was just one
of those guys I kept doodling over and over.”
Commercial watchers might even remember a
very early version of Doug bouncing around
on a pogo stick in his signature vest for
a 1989 Florida grapefruit juice commercial,
and he and his prized pooch Porkchop were
later seen in a 1990 USA Network commercial.
Bluffington is real
Eventually, Jinkins collected his drawings
into a book called Doug Got a New Pair of
Shoes and sent a copy to a Nickelodeon executive,
which led to the network ordering an eight-minute
pilot episode called "Doug Can't Dance." Jinkins
immediately went to work creating his own
production studio to make it happen.
As he began developing other characters for
the series, Jinkins again drew inspiration
from his own life and the people he knew.
“He’s kind of how I remember childhood,
growing up…”
Doug's love interest Patti Mayonnaise, for
example, was based on Jinkins' own childhood
crush. Supporting characters Roger Klotz and
Doug’s best friend, Skeeter Valentine, were
also based on people Jinkins grew up with.
No instruments needed
You probably know that mega-famous voice actor
Billy West, also known for voicing the title
characters for Nickelodeon’s popular cartoon
series The Ren & Stimpy Show, was cast to
portray Doug.
“...he’s a painfully shy 11 ½ year old.”
However, West wasn't the only voice actor
to make a major impact on the show. Actor
Fred Newman was brought on to voice some of
the zanier-sounding characters — including
Porkchop, Skeeter, and Mr. Dink.
“You can call me Mr. Dink.”
Newman even ended up creating that earworm
of a theme song using the simplest of tools.
Of that catchy intro, Newman explained,
"That wasn't Doug's voice, that was actually
my voice. [...] We wanted to use as much as
we could household objects, things that a
kid could have, make it sound innocent.”
That’s right -- Newman relied on his unique
beatboxing and "honking" skills to create
a lot of the sounds heard throughout the catchy
intro.
The rainbow rebuke
The title character of Doug and his family
were drawn to be very obviously Caucasian,
but many other characters in the series boasted
rather unusual skin colors — from Skeeter's
teal complexion, to Roger's lime green tone,
to Beebe Bluff's purplish appearance. However,
Jinkins insists he wasn't trying to make any
major socio-political statements with his
colorful cast of characters.
Jinkins told HuffPost of the controversy over
his main character's skin tone:
"People are certain that Skeeter is an African-American
guy. I'm like, ‘Well, he's blue!' [...] If
that's how you see him, that's great. It's
not a bad thing, but I never planned it. Skeeter
is blue and he's Doug's friend."
A network tangle
Following its original 52-episode run from
1991 to 1994, Nickelodeon declined an option
to renew Doug for a new season, despite Jinkins
being signed for 65 episodes. The decision,
which reportedly came as a shock, was based
upon some budget tightening underway at Nickelodeon.
However, Nickelodeon’s voluntary loss was
Disney's gain, as it allowed the House of
Mouse to scoop up the production rights and
studio for Doug and proceed with carrying
the hit show forward. The show was retooled
as Brand Spanking New! Doug as part of the
ABC Saturday Morning Cartoon lineup for three
additional seasons and spawned a live-action
musical, a line of toy merchandise with fast-food
cross-marketing, and even a film called Doug's
First Movie.
A not so happy ending
The saga of Doug Funnie and Patti Mayonnaise
never quite came to a close, leaving fans
to wonder whether the green-vested gentleman
managed to win Patti’s heart for the long
haul. According to Jinkins, the answer is
likely no. He told Entertainment Weekly that
he couldn't picture the two ending up together
as adults because it's just not realistic,
saying,
"Most people don't end up with their first
love."
Perhaps Jinkins is merely jaded, based on
his own experience later in life with the
real-life person who inspired Patti. In a
Nic k Animation podcast, he recounted his
reunion with the woman in question and admitted
that they didn't enjoy some sudden romance,
despite his hopes that it might happen. After
she reached out to invite him to dinner, Jinkins
admitted to wondering if something might spark…
until she said,
"Oh, I want you to meet my husband!"
Sorry, Doug.